make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so in the last video we did on the
immortal Hulk ah we had done technically
only like four of the five the issues
that we were supposed to write and the
whole reason why was because this issues
gonna be double sized right so it was
like okay we don't really have enough
time to fit it all into a reasonable
time frame I know some of you guys would
love it if I made videos that were like
45 minutes long but the realities that
we just can't really do that in a
feasible way right you know for most of
the people on the channel they were just
kind of be like alright that's a little
nuts the fact remains here I'm glad I
waited right because this double-sized
issue is kind of crazy right it's it's
not really a descent into madness but
it's certainly wildly intriguing right
and it definitely is one of those it's
gonna take us a little bit of time to
get through but this particular comic
and this is something that I didn't
notice right off the bat and in fact I
read this when it came out and then
waited a day and now I'm recording it I
actually had to read it like two or
three times to really understand
everything that was going on here
because it was just so far away from
what I'm normally used to but this
actually takes place in the 9th unit in
the 9th multiverse right it takes place
in the next multiverse and the reason
why is because at the II at the end of
one of the more recent stories the
immortal Hulk had basically ended up at
the very end of all reality right like
the end of the entire time stream when
everything comes to an end and I still
stick by the idea that it was possessed
by the one below all right the one below
wall had totally taken control of the
immortal Hulk and in that in fact this
actually confirms it but the one below
all had basically taken complete and
total control of the immortal Hulk and
it kind of gone on a rampage and what it
had done was made it to the very end of
time we didn't know what all had done we
simply known and it just made it to the
very end of time and then consume the
sentience of that universe right the
idea that was was essentially kind of a
repeat of Galactus right Galan was the
last survivor of his of his own universe
and in fact the multiverse and
ultimately was reborn into the newest
iteration of the multiverse as Galactus
basically it was really seeming like it
was gonna be the same thing that in some
former fashion Incredible Hulk would
become like what was basically the new
Galactus but the immortal Hulk consumed
his sentience of the universe like
literally ate it took all of this energy
and basically the new multiverse was a
given form we're not really given a
timeframe here all we're told is at some
point between when the new multiverse
came into existence and this moment here
the immortal Hulk has destroyed
everything and it's kind of nuts right
as it's kind of crazy here because what
we end up getting are what I call
basically like these post humans they're
not really a race through there and in
reality it's kind of interesting because
al Ewing gives us like a man
woman in so far as you can just because
of the fact of the way these creatures
are designed of the way they look aside
from their colors you know blue and and
pink are really not traditionally a man
or a woman right but this picks up with
it being whose name is actually spelled
interestingly it's P AR % l right so I'm
gonna say like parcel or Perl you know
something along those lines will say
parcel is because you know % and then L
so you know personal or something along
those lines but regardless this being
has is basically tasked with like
perusing the cosmos and has been for
some time perusing the entirety of
either the universe or the multiverse
itself and then trying to basically
figure out if there's anything left and
what is basically realized is that there
isn't that basically all the worlds in
the in the entirety of this universe all
totally broken there's nothing left all
the worlds are completely eradicated and
completely destroyed and there's nothing
left here it's just a giant expanse of
what's basically blackness and like some
planets that have been torn to rubble
and so on and so forth but it literally
looks like a massive explosion went off
in the universe and so what this does is
it leads to parcel coming to encounter
another being by the name of what we're
gonna call we're gonna call it Danielle
you know just for the sake of it but
with the two of they're communicating we
need a couple cool things here the first
is that they don't use traditional
speech right they don't use words hence
the reason why we can consider them
posthuman because of the fact that they
seem to have evolved beyond that there's
no real indication that they were human
at one point in time and it's just kind
of the best description I can come to
out with the exception of the fact that
it is a wholly different race that
existed out there but regardless of the
situation they use these kind of plants
you know device is more or less to
communicate and what they basically
discuss here is the existence of things
and and what parcel basically says is
third there's nothing left there's
there's no life no nothing we're it like
we're the only things left in this this
Universal space everything else has been
destroyed by the creature and that's all
they really describe it as is the
creature and it really kind of presents
a scenario of hopelessness here because
what this does and the way this is
depicted it almost seems like this
universe is coming to an end and in a
lot of ways it is it's being done
prematurely but it's coming to an end
and it begs a lot of questions here when
this new universe was created how did it
look
where there's similarities there was it
this universe came into existence and
then right off the bat the the immortal
Hulk started killing everything the
reality is is from what we've seen in
the timelines
when a universe comes into existence you
basically get this explosion this kind
of big bang that leads to you know
really like the formation of the
Celestials which leads to the aspirins
on the war between the two
that always breaks out the Celestials
start creating life and different things
like that but the overall gist here is
that time passes right like it takes
some time even with Galactus Galactus
lay dormant for billions of years before
he emerged and consumed that consumed
his first world time passes from one
point to the next from the beginning of
the universe to when life starts popping
up so it's not like this universe was
created than all life sprung into
existence maybe it did again we don't
really know the origins of this place
all we know is that between the time it
came into existence and now the immortal
Hookers has destroyed everything but
notice this the immortal Hulk is almost
depicted as like this mythical figure
right like these guys they know it as
the creature but it's like they've never
encountered it before but they've never
actually met it before all they know are
they all it done is like witness you
know the destruction that's that's been
brought here so there's a lot of
ambiguity here but what you also end up
learning here is that there are these
things called tiding fly so this
particular group were able to create and
tiding flies are a means of
communication but they're a means of
communication that spans both time and
space right so if they give it like a
telephone or you could call somebody in
the past and that's basically what this
is these these organisms that are
created that are normally supposed to be
bred under regular circumstances or have
been engineered here because what this
is designed to do is show a moment of
panic now again because there's so much
this unexplained with regards to this
race how its culture functions and and
how it operates uh so on and so forth
the only thing we know is that the means
by which these tide flies were I guess
these tiny flies were created is
considered to be heresy that they were
artificially created as opposed to
basically being born so to speak you
know for lack of a better word but the
result here is that Parcells basically
tasked with taking this tiding fly and
sending it to the past i here's the
funny thing about this it's Parcells
responses well that's ridiculous though
because like it would lead to the
destruction of all things because we
don't know how it would change the past
and the response of Daniela's but like
everything's screwed up anyway though so
look here's like it doesn't matter it
can't get any worse than it is right now
the only way direction from here is up
and so as a result of that parcel takes
its hiding fly and leaves right ends up
ends up departing here and that's when
we start to get into like this
appearance of the immortal Hulk and
things popping off and this is when it
all really gets cool because what you
end up getting is as parcel basically
showing up to the homeworld of their
planet right the home run of their
people and again we're not given a whole
lot of information here outside of what
it looks like a lot of how the tribe
functions and it doesn't really matter
anyway and the reason why is because
parcel notices offer the distance this
green light and realizes that the
immortal Hulk is
coming for them and so the results of
this is that when the immortal soul gets
there this guy is colossal right and
this is the funny thing about it is when
you think of The Incredible Hulk as a
being that can basically transcend and
go into like the universal space that
you think of that you're like okay so
this is cool this is interesting but
like The Incredible Hulk would still for
the most part be the same size right
because you think of the Incredible Hulk
and you say okay the biggest he's ever
really been was part of the monster
right when he was just colossal and
sized because he just been feeding off
of so much energy so you kind of chalk
that up and you say okay he might be
about that big that's basically it but
when you're talking about a version of
the immortal Hulk that's really just
kinda like a vector for the force of the
one below all basically this is an ultra
powerful entity right we'll talk more
about this here in a second once we
actually get into how the one above one
below all is involved in all this and so
far as how its you know how it sounds
funky ting here but basically you're
talking about a cosmic level Hulk is
really what you're talking about here a
cosmic level of the immortal Hulk that's
as big as a planet because literally
he's flying through this system flying
through moons and so on and so forth and
these moons look like they're about the
size of like grapefruits in comparison
to the size of the Incredible Hulk so it
literally just shows up and just punches
the planet like it's the craziest thing
it shows up and just like punches the
planet shatters it destroys it and
basically all things are pretty much
dead now like every all forms of life in
the universe are dead it's safe--for
parcel who manages us in this tiding fly
out actually time to the modern day in
order to keep this from happening but
one of the things that parcel does is it
basically communes and and mentally
bonds with the immortal Hulk simply
asking a question why are you doing all
this and this is what we start to get
into what's going on with the one below
all that what is it happening here is
that when this communication takes place
that it's not simply the immortal Hulk
being controlled by the one below all
tearing everything up that what it's
been doing is as it's been going through
and killing all these various races and
in these groups out there that has been
in turn consuming their souls right so
like all these souls all these forms of
life are confined within the within the
the immortal Hulk which essentially is
is really appearing to help bolster its
power and then all of that in turn is
being controlled by the one below all
that somewhere along the line the
immortal Hulk as we know him in the
moment right now in the present day in
in Marvel Comics has been totally taken
over controlled and dominated by the one
below wall who now uses the body of the
immortal Hulk as a vector right like
uses it as a means for it to take
control right so it's like removing the
immortal Hulk from the shell that is its
physical body
and then the one below all stepping in
its place but here is the big question
that I had here right because what the
one below all basically says is like I
am the one below all right with the
power that I have all I want to do is
destroy things like I am a being powered
by hate all I want to do is destroy and
eradicate all things which I've
basically succeeded in doing the
question we would ask here is where is
the one above all where's like the
Living Tribunal different things like
that and for a lot of those cosmic
entities for the Living Tribunal for
like the Phoenix force and for you know
the the other entities like eternity and
so on and so forth we can basically go
on what the one below all is right it's
the antithesis to the one above all
meaning that they would have to
basically be equal in power or the very
least with the purpose that they serve
the fact is that one below all was cast
down by the one above all indicates the
one above all is even only marginally
more powerful than the one below all but
regardless of the situation the fact
remains that you're talking about it
being that's more than enough to destroy
the Living Tribunal any one of those
guys who are out there right so assuming
the laning tribunal even intervened and
even stepped in and never stood a chance
in the first place right it never had a
chance to basically win but as far as
the one above all goes this is where our
viewing is being a little damn being a
little bit ambiguous here now in truth
we can kind of run on the position of
the one above all historically immoral
college now for those of you guys who
are familiar with it the woman or what
above all almost never appears and never
action in fact there's only ever really
been a couple of times where it has
three times were the one above all has
actually acted or done something that
allowed it to interact with a larger
various superheroes who were out there
right the first real instance of that
came when the one above all interacted
with the Fantastic Four and took on the
form of Jack Kirby the second instance
of that came when the one but one above
all took on the form of a homeless man
and interacted with Peter Parker in
order to basically say hey look
sometimes folks not you know it sucks in
Aunt May's die but that's just kind of
the way that it goes right it's just the
nature of things it's all part of the
plan you don't have to understand that
you just have to accept it the final
time that I'm aware of with the one
above all actually interacting was
during a Jim Sterling's conclusion for
his whole infinity saga after the events
of Secret Wars when the Living Tribunal
had died and the result was that Adam
warlock of that alternate reality was
tasked with becoming the New Living
Tribunal and was appointed to that
position after after encountering and
speaking directly with the one above all
and that's it the one of them all almost
never really acts and model really kind
of takes the stance of saying well if it
happened in the Marvel Universe
it happened because it's part of the
plan of the one above all right like the
one above all allows it to basically
happen
reality based on what we've seen the
water above all is an absentee landlord
right like he never does anything like
it's it's kind of crazy it's like why do
you even exist if you don't do anything
at all it's really kind of crazy there
ah but what seems to be going on here is
is one of those things because it's not
kind of like events are being set in
motion and and you would above all only
ever really seems to act under the
circumstance whereby it's it's Council
is basically needed in the case of like
when it spoke to Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four and said hey look you
know here's basically the cycle of life
and death
when it spoke to Peter Parker about the
same thing or when it was the case of
the Living Tribunal and somebody had to
take the living tribunals place and only
the one above all can appoint someone to
that position aside from that it's the
only time that it ever really seems to
act and so we can kind of look at this
and we could say okay so the reason why
the one above all never really decided
to take a stance here is because of this
very action of this tiding fly being
sent back to the past it was a way out
right the one above all didn't need to
act it's really indirectly al Ewing is
essentially saying this is all gonna be
averted this is all going to be stopped
and so the one below all will basically
be stopped before this future can come
into existence in the first place and it
successfully destroys everything right
so it's kind of interesting there it's
sort of a way where Marvel kind of
answers his own question they sort of
answered that question by virtue of the
story or they leave it to us but it is
intriguing albeit a little bit sad to
basically know that one below all
usually its power through the immortal
Hulk killed everybody right and killed
Thanos and it killed like all the
Avengers and the x-men and and everybody
assuming they all even existed in this
timeline in the first place and so as a
result of that what we basically get is
this kind of last little tidbit that
everything is broken that everything has
gone here that in this future were the
one above our were the one below all you
know basically uses the immortal Hulk
that the one below all wins right like
it basically comes out on top here that
everything will continue to be destroyed
all things will basically come to an end
here and there will be nothing left
right because if the sentience of the
universe was essentially eradicated by
the one below all and in turn the one
below all created this new you know
universe and then destroyed everything
in it then the buck stops here there is
nothing else there's no more universes
coming after this there's no more life
here there's no sentience of the
universe to die and recreate everything
that's it there's no going forward this
is where it ends right which is
something that we've never seen before
even if you look at the what-if stories
Jean Grey becomes adored Phoenix and she
wipes out the universe the universe
would be reborn again because all that
life existed there for the sentience of
the universe's exist had exist
but that sentience of the universe was
never destroyed it was one of those
things were like you would basically die
of its own volition insofar as it would
kind of coalesce in on itself and then
be reborn into a new universe this
doesn't it doesn't happen here there is
no symptom to the universe there's no
nothing everything is gone here because
what you basically have is the most
powerful form of the incredible hulk
ever created in the history of Marvel
going on a warpath and consuming and
destroying everything so it's kind of
nuts right like the one below all Hulk
like it's it's crazy it turns out this
level of power we've never really seen
this from anyone like it's it's kind of
nuts here but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
know this one was pretty abstract
relatively speaking to the stories of
what kind of use - it's one of the
things that al Ewing acknowledged he was
kind of hey guys so when you read this
story you're gonna see some crazy stuff
and it's gonna look pretty bonkers
don't let that turn you off to it I
doubted the rest of this is gonna look
that way it's really just designed to
show what the universe would look like
in the far-flung future when everything
comes crashing down but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here - comments
explain and make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the rod 4
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]